[Music]
with the perfect timing and the right
angles the image is in a photo have the
ability to trick everyone these pictures
are fun and cool to look at but we
definitely have to look at them twice to
really understand what's going on if
you're new to our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we'll be showing
you ten pictures that will make you look
twice just wait until you see what
happens when an end comes in contact
with a helicopter it will trip you out
an upside-down world an artist by the
name of Philip format creates some very
interesting artwork that will leave you
scratching your head and confusion the
French conceptual artist loves to create
pieces that play with the viewers mind
his gravity-defying pictures are
digitally altered and repositioned to
make us all wonder what's going on here
if you look at this photo and you're
immediately confused don't worry you're
not alone you definitely have to look at
his work twice to really figure things
out and this artwork a man can be seen
standing on a wooden balcony as he gazes
off into the distance you can see that
the doorframe is actually attached to a
body of water in the distance the city
skyline is twisted at an angle and it
makes us wonder which way is up and
which way is down Philips art defies
logic but that's what makes all of his
work so interesting and intriguing when
the laws of the physical world are
pushed and artists can create anything
they put their mind to dangerous or not
with a little bit of camera trickery and
placing things at specific angles you
can create a scene that appears to be
really dangerous this man decided to
spend the day out having fun with his
family he held his baby in the air to
get a better look at the city and the
passing train at first glance it looks
like this dad is putting his child in
grave danger it appears that he's
holding the baby high up in the air so
he can take a look at the city below
them but if you look a second time
you'll notice that they're not standing
high above the city at all it's a
miniature set of train cars and tiny
buildings the man and his family are
standing right next to the display on
ground level
sothanks believed this baby isn't really
in that much danger at all it's all
about the angle in which the picture is
taken were you pulled by this photo the
first time you saw it let us know down
below in the comments section two-headed
dog a Soviet scientist in the 1950s is
well known for attaching too
dog heads on to one body but since then
two-headed dogs are something that just
doesn't exist
most people are obsessed with the idea
of any creature that's two-headed and
that's why this viral photo caught
everyone's attention when this photo was
posted online the internet went
absolutely crazy it really does look
like a living breathing two-headed dog
doesn't it taken in a parking lot this
picture shows what appears to be a cute
and cuddly black-and-white dog with two
heads and one body but again this is all
about the way the picture is taken the
odd camera angle makes it look like
these fluffy dogs are sharing one body
and that's just not the case there are
actually two separate dogs in this photo
one dog is standing in front of the
other and the dog in the back body is
completely covered by the dog on the
front
these dogs lined up perfectly at just
the right moment to create a tricky
photo that looks like something out of a
sci-fi movie coming in for landing one
of the best things about photography is
the endless amounts of creativity
looking at things in a different way and
changing your perspective allows you to
see and create things that may not even
be humanly possible tweaking the
perspective on certain photos is not
only fun but it can also create visually
amazing masterpieces just like this one
an ant was having some fun chillin on
top of an ice-cold drink in the distance
you can see a helicopter flying around
when you put these things together an
amazing and captivating photo comes to
life although we know that an ant is
much tinier than a helicopter the angle
this photo is taken makes them appear to
be on the same scale as the ant walks
along the top of the cop it looks like
the helicopter is about to land right
next to it how many times did you have
to look at this photo before you could
grasp what was really going on do you
think the photographer uses Photoshop or
simply a different perspective welcome
to the gun show this girl definitely
looks like she's been putting in some
work in the gym or maybe not when we
first looked at this photo we thought
she was pouring some pretty massive arms
full of defined muscles but just like
all the other photos on this list things
aren't always what they seem
let's take a closer look at this picture
so we can figure out what's really going
on this beautiful girl is standing with
her arms tightly pulled all the way back
behind her behind her is a guy but you
can't see him at all he's completely
hidden behind her except for his arms he
holds his arms up just above her
shoulders so that it appears that his
arms actually belong to her
the result is an optical illusion that
makes this girl look like she can
benchpress more than Arnold
Schwarzenegger and we love the serious
look on her face this is one girl you're
not going to want to mess with wouldn't
it be fun to take a hilarious picture
like this with one of your friends tiny
man have you ever tried to take a tricky
photo to make things seem different from
what they appear it's a bit difficult to
recreate these moments if you try too
hard sometimes it's just best to let
things happen naturally
it's these unrehearsed and unplanned
moments that make for some of the best
and mind-boggling pictures we've ever
seen take a look at this photo for
example we can't stop looking at it
without completely cracking up there's a
shirtless guy standing around in a pair
of shorts and a hat and some sneakers
with a pair of funky socks directly in
front of him is a trash can
the photographer's stood behind the
trash can to take the photo and as you
can see the results are hilarious when
you first glance at this picture doesn't
look like the guy is super duper tiny it
looks like he's no more than 2 inches
tall and because of the position of
where he is it really looks like he's
standing directly on top of the trash
can this is just another perfect shot
taken at the perfect moment extra-long
dog have you ever seen a really big dog
in real life we're not talking about a
Rottweiler or a Doberman we're talking
about huge dogs here Great Danes stand
about 30 inches tall and sometimes they
can be even bigger the tallest dog in
the world was a Great Dane named Zeus
who stood at 44 inches tall
can you believe that that's taller than
your average three-year-old child but
it's not too often that you see a dog
that large and that's why this photo is
so amazing
when you first look at it what do you
see most people see a super long dog
standing behind a trash can but of
course things aren't what they seem to
be there are actually two dogs in this
photo the dog in the back hits his head
concealed by the trash can and the dog
in the front body is hidden by the trash
can the way these two dogs are standing
makes their bodies appear to be
connected even though we know there were
two dogs in this picture wouldn't it be
cool if the dog with this long in real
life sitting on water there are two
things most kids dream of doing one of
them is the ability to fly on her own
and the
is the ability to stand on water who
knows maybe one day technology and
science will allow us all to have these
superpowers but for now the only way
these things are possible is if we
utilize our camera trickery skills check
out this young girl who spent the day
out of pool while someone stood nearby
to take a photo the girl decided to take
a dip into the water as she jumped into
the pool the camera took the picture at
just the right moment when you look at
this photo what do you see
do you see the girl kneeling down on top
of the swimming pool so do we it really
looks like she's able to defy gravity
and suspend herself right on top of the
water
of course this photo was taken at the
right moment and the position of her
knees line up perfectly next to the
level of the water in the swimming pool
this gave the appearance that she was
kneeling on the water even though she
really isn't pretty cool right
doct have you ever seen anything like
this before neither have we
this photo was taken in South Korea and
it shows a huge crew sitting on the edge
of a cliff we have so many questions
running through our minds how did the
ship get there are there people stranded
inside well believe it or not your eyes
aren't playing tricks on you this ship
really is docked on a mountain
overlooking a beach but it's not what it
appears to be this is the Sun cruise
hotel that's located in a South Korean
tourist town the 540 foot cruise ship
themed resort has 211 guest rooms for
visitors restaurants pools a golf course
and an indoor gym the hotel was created
to give tourists the experience of going
on a cruise without actually being on
one inside the wall of the ship sounds
of crashing waves and birds chirping are
playing to make people feel like they're
at sea to this day the dock cruise ship
is one of the most popular tourist
attractions in South Korea would you
like to visit this cruise ship hotel one
day let us know by leaving us a reply in
the comments section restaurant this
photo is beyond strange it's almost as
if we stepped into a parallel universe
we have to say this best photo for last
because it stopped us right dirt tracks
we have to look at it for a few minutes
to really understand what is going on
this photo hasn't been altered in any
way it just so happens that these three
sets of friends were dining out if
time if we didn't know any better we
would think these people all called each
other the night before to coordinate
their outfits each group has two people
sitting down for lunch the women sitting
closest to the camera are all wearing
shades of red and their guests sitting
directly across from them all have on
various shades of green to top it off
they also have very similar hairstyles
this makes it look like it's the same
group of friends in each booth but it's
not it is purely coincidental that they
all showed up wearing similar outfits
and looking almost exactly the same
whoever took this photo definitely needs
an award because it's not too often that
you see something like this in real life
which of these photos really tripped you
out the most let us know down below in
the comment section and please subscribe
and give us a thumbs up if you enjoyed
10 pictures that will make you look
twice
[Music]